I hope they got a glimpse of the Titanic
before it ended
wouldn't that be nice I hope they got a
little glimpse of it because this is a
movie by the way
don't think for a minute
this is not a movie two pakistanis in
there
diversity honey
no not Jesus Christ thank you Lord
because now the new movie rules get up
the new movie rules what do you need to
be eligible for an Academy Award I think
you need 30 marginalized and you got
them in that tin can here's the thing
we all want to be in the can but not
like we're all curious about what's
going on in the can
we all have our own can you never know
when your can
will get called
enjoy the can
you don't know how long you got in the
Canton Troy the can